welcome aboard everyone welcome back to
Hot Breath the show where you learn
comedy from the pros I am your host
comedian Joel Byers and our mission here
is to cultivate the next generation of
great Comics been interviewing today's
comedy greats and our guest today his
comedy Journey started at the age of 17
in a Detroit jazz club and just a year
later he picks up moves to La where he
quickly found success as a regular at
The Comedy Store he had an HBO special
produced by George Carlin he was even a
stand-in for Andy Kaufman on Taxi but
since this stand-up days he's done a few
things like you know direct specials for
Bill Burr and Adam Sandler movie he just
recently did The Comedy Store
documentary
but now we are excited that he is doing
hot breath today so if you want to be a
part of these this is from our weekly
live stream we do a live q a every
single Wednesday on our YouTube channel
so go subscribe there and welcome to the
hot breath verse Mr Mike binder everyone
yes
thanks Joel I appreciate you having me
on of course
oh my gosh you like the show
yeah I do yeah and I think
sorry all right what are all those kids
locked in your basement what is this
hahaha
Jesus oh now I know why you quit comedy
okay
that's right Hey listen
because I had a perverted mind and uh
hey uh
uh um
no this is great I love I love also what
you said about you know being able to
help the next generation of stand-ups I
think that's a really fantastic thing
yeah I mean this show really started as
like what I wish existed as a comedian
and um since grown it seems to be a
sentiment for a lot of people
you know Howie Mandel and I are doing a
show we're working on a show called just
kidding where we we get all these
comedians that started in their teens
and each one of them mentors a teen
comic and then we're gonna end it it's
10 episodes and the 10th episode's gonna
be uh
at Just for Laughs
the festival how he owns and and um
and it's not like a competition it's
just all of them are going to perform
for this this great concert after being
mentored by these Giants of Comedy who
all started in their teens
I I just did a thing with national
pediatric Cancer Foundation for a kid
who wants to be a comedian as well so I
know if you're looking for kids but um
he may be a good candidate
yeah no it's moral in their teens you
know mm-hmm
cancer is boring yeah that's a good
point yeah it's it's so passe yeah it's
very hack I told him that you know but I
mean if you can get some kids dying to
the coronavirus then we got something
topical Joel
that's the 90s 2000s
so I'm I'm super excited to have you on
here and this is a q a as well so people
watching live we got some peeps watching
so feel free to comment with any
questions y'all have here I know people
are dming me questions but um if y'all
have uh questions here put them in the
live chat and um just just to kick it
off here I mean you've been in the
comedy game so long the comedy game is
evolving so much it's like where do you
see
where do you see comedy is because even
you tracking The Comedy Store
documentary and you sing the evolution
of Comedy through that time span like
where do you see with where comedy is
now where do you see it headed and how
can the Next Generation really take
advantage and really start creating
their own success
well that's a great question because I
I'm so positive about the stand-up
comedy world and scene and art right now
and I would say just being on your show
just the fact that you've done this and
I would say I would say to anyone a
young person or any or an old person
just getting started in comedy
just dive in the water and be bold and
don't be worried about who says yes to
you you've got to say yes to yourself
and and in this modern world that's what
I love about it I mean Joel you just
said yes to yourself and created your
own
you know I think what would you call it
the buyers buyers verse or whatever the
hot breath averse have breath averse you
know I mean I I love that I love what
you're doing that's why I wanted to be
on the show because I applaud it I love
what
Mark Maron did in his garage I loved
what Bill Burr did on his couch and
you know
talking to all these guys you realize
no they didn't get someone didn't say
yes to them and give them a pile of
money or starting thing but they did
something a little harder a little more
ballsy they just hung in there one one
follower at a time which I'm sure you
know yeah it takes you know and every
one of these guys that's been really
successful Joe and
Phil and Whitney and everyone I I feel
like the the common denominator is they
hung with it they stay they stayed with
it so I feel like if you want to look up
I'm 64 and I'm just getting back into
stand up
and I don't know where it's going to go
I really don't
but I do know that if it's going to go
anywhere it's not going to be me getting
signed by anybody or or any or Netflix
or HBO or anyone saying yes to me
because they're not gonna It's Gonna be
Me doing my own damn thing and building
my own damn thing and having a really
good time doing it and
not only do you have to be ballsy I
think you have to be really hard on
yourself I wouldn't ever lay anything
down unless it was great
yeah that was we just had Paul verzi on
here and
incredible and the thing he talked about
with this new Netflix special was he
wanted it to be special he wanted it to
be something that's like people watch it
and they remember it and they want to
like share it and I think he was
referencing like so many people
releasing specials now but like you
reference it's like making sure it's
something you're proud of that you would
like want to live on forever and Paul's
one of those guys who just hasn't
stopped and now he has a Netflix special
and by the way I I went I jumped up with
him
at a club in San Diego last weekend with
him in bartnick you know Joe bartnick
who I just love two guys in general and
and um
[__] verts can I swear I can swear
yeah let it rip let her rip Mike
had a whole another hour
after doing it special after special
aired a week later week earlier and then
there's verzie up there with a whole
another hour and it was so good and I
thought what an animal and um
the only one I've ever seen do that is
Bill Burr you know
yeah I was gonna say yeah that explains
why Bill Burr liked him so much early on
yeah yeah they're good buddies that's
how I met him actually let's do Bill
yeah
and you met bill on the the movie set
right on black or white
yeah
and then from there you guys were just
like comedy soul mates yeah it was
really great because
there was going to be Jason Sudeikis at
least we thought and then something
happened he couldn't do it and at the
last minute we were about two weeks from
shooting and I was just in my room and I
uh my friend clay who's built my house
and is a really good buddy of mine would
always tell me about this guy Bill Burr
on YouTube and it was like another error
in my life I thought well if easy on
YouTube means he ain't any good okay and
if I haven't heard of him means he ain't
any good you know and which a lot of
comics in my generation have that
attitude because they don't know about
this whole other world and
190 comes on uh Conan
I'm sitting in my hotel room and I just
man this guy's great and I called Kevin
Costner I said turn the TV on and watch
this guy right now
because he could play this role
and um
he I called Kevin said yes and I called
Sharon bialy
who knew him who's cast all my movies
and she had casted him in a smaller role
on Breaking Bad
and then it turned out he was with my
manager's company
so I just got his number and I called
him and he was he was unbelievable he
was like
do I gotta read I went no he goes well
that you know I'd have to cat
cancel a bunch of dates
and I had Club dates and uh I said well
can you do it he said yeah and can you
get on a plane like tonight
and he did
wow he came down he came down and
everybody loved the guy you know he just
was everybody everybody just loved him
what what is what did what did everyone
love about him what is Bill seems to
have something like he seems to have the
sauce
yeah well he's a great actor they love
they loved what the job he was doing but
plus he's funny and if you don't know
him too well you don't you don't get you
know you you kind of like him when you
get to know him a lot more you don't
like him as much
I think the people that those people he
was new to us all put it that way oh
yeah yeah it was that honeymoon phase of
it I guess yeah no no he was he was
great he was great he was great in the
movie and we've become great friends
ever since we've hung out so much and
done so many things together
we have a new special coming out next
Friday night called Live at Red Rocks
on Netflix it's unbelievable it's I
think it's the best thing he's ever done
and he and I produced it together and I
directed it but he uh
he it's him man he just he put together
an hour that's just incredible I just
love it
yeah he he's one of those Comics you
watch and it's like oh that's where
comedy is like I'm 12 years in sometimes
I feel good about like some of the
comedy I can do and then it is like
seeing someone like Bill Burr and it's
like oh there's so many more Decades of
work to do
well he's done it so long and so
consistently
and you know he knows it too you know
he'll give him some advice like don't
tell me what to do I've been doing it
too long I got it down the way I like it
I don't want to hear anything I was like
you're right oh I'll have the camera
over here Mr Burr yeah
and the big thing uh that's real
inspiring about what he's doing with all
things comedy is it is like it seems to
be this like four Comics by Comics
platform which is what we're like
building here at hot breath but it's
really like Comics helping comics and
just letting the funny rise to the top
you know
that's right that's right
so it's good to know at that level even
Comics like his level are still thinking
about like younger comics and how they
can help out and really
he does a lot I he has he has a really
good ability to have empathy for new
Comics I really appreciate that about
Bill
he's really and he's really he's I've
seen him when young Comics come up to
him he's always
he's he's top top shelf
ah I'm excited to have him on here
so the questions
let's get into some people's questions
here
let her rip yeah go for it focused go
for it by the way this year let me show
you this cigar I'm going to smoke
I don't know what is
is that a joke is that a Joe Rogan
all right could have smoked a Bill Burr
what
it's a long story we'll get into it
later
wow did you get that from Joe when you
did the documentary
just oh I got it I got Joe those cigars
too my buddy Nick malilio and he loves
them oh you're the plug okay
and uh
and um he has this company called
Foundation cigars that are just
fantastic and we're going to do a whole
series of comedians cigars on my site
standupworld.com for to raise money for
the um the the comedy stores Family Fun
which is comedians in crisis fun wow
there's going to end up being about
eight comedians with their own brand
cigars and there's going to be five each
one's going to have 500 limited 500 box
run
and they're gonna all the money is gonna
go towards uh the The Comedy Store
Family Fund
oh that's when is that dropping
probably this September we're working on
it right now but it's it should be
really soon that's awesome I know I look
I look like a Mormon but maybe I'll have
to get some just to Edge it up a little
bit you know yeah yeah
I brought the chest hair out to try to
show a little Edge but God damn if I had
known that
foreign
would have been a lot shorter
so yeah we got we got several peeps
commenting with questions here so yeah
come on in ask your questions here for
the the one and only Mike binder it
looks like the first one we have here
is
um ah people saying they love the comedy
story documentary thank you for
capturing history yeah well it was
really good the the weird thing I I did
I researched you before doing this I
hadn't heard this brought up but you
came up in urban rooms in Detroit but
then you forgot about that Tuesdays on
the I didn't forget about Fat Tuesday
Fat Tuesday got their own documentary
I didn't forget about Fat Tuesday this
is the problem
I picked that you know how many other
shows I didn't do
there was Fat Tuesday wasn't the only
only group that had their own show
uh-huh you know you you know but
listen they whine loud enough they got
their own documentary and I loved it I
thought it was great but Fat Tuesday
wasn't I didn't I can give you nine
different comedy The Comedy Store
players I didn't do anything on The
Comedy Store La Jolla the dunes era and
comedy you know there were all kinds of
crazy nights that that you know uh uh
what happened we lost Mike
we lost Mike can you hear me I can hear
you yes it's so funny we're talking
about the the Black Knight at comedy
store and then your screen went black oh
how funny
there you are you got answered me you
sent me yeah this is a gotcha we're
doing all this to get Mike binder
canceled no right but I so I didn't
forget about him it's just that
uh even with five episodes I didn't have
time to do anything you know so hmm and
there were so many people said how come
you're not talking about La Jolla how
come you're not talking about she's
going on the La Jolla Comedy Store how
come you're not talking about The Comedy
Store players and and doing a section on
that or or Arab nights the Mitzi had an
Arab night you know and
not an Arab I I guess it was Middle
Eastern but but anyway listen Fat
Tuesday was awesome and they ended up
getting a great documentary out of it
yeah for sure I I just hadn't heard that
uh somebody asked that question or do
you ask no I I was thinking of that
because I knew you came up in a lot of
all black rooms and then that made me
think of oh yeah The Fat Tuesday and
that wasn't in the documentary so that's
I just like went eight well not only
that here's the other side of it is
and I said this in the documentary Mitzi
Shore was into diversity so many years
before everybody else
she always was all in Japanese comic of
this oh that's great I want to get more
women Comics I want to get you know and
but it was if you looked at any lineup
back then there were so many black
Comics there were so many
you know women good women eventually
when she when Mitzi said her mind to it
and she was she was but she was into
people being different long before
anyone even used that word diversity so
I you know as great as Fat Tuesday was
any of one of those Comics that were in
that documentary that were really funny
got any of this any spots they wanted
you know what's interesting is that
comedy like you because you were there
for all like the the strikes and all
that and it seems like comedian pay at
least in like the Comedy Club Circuit it
seems like it's been the same forever
like I feel like everyone gets paid the
same now as ever
it's really sad
I couldn't believe it when I heard that
but listen it's been this it's the same
look there's also a caveat to that those
clubs like The Comedy Store and the
impov and the Laugh Factory are in town
it's very easy
there that the comedians get more than
just money out of them oh yeah go down
there then go down there and work out
material or have a home Club a place to
hang a place to get sharp on Monday
Tuesday Wednesday night
so when they go out Thursday Friday and
Saturday make money they're they're 10
prick Sharp
yeah that's what I meant for like clubs
across the country like if you're
hosting or emceeing like that pay that
pay has been the same since like forever
and asked a club owner about it and he
said it's all Supply demand I can't
speak for that because I
I mean I happen to have been one of the
first
Headliners at a comedy club in the
country which the first the first other
than
other than um
the San Francisco New York and La there
were no comedy clubs when we started you
know and after post this post Steve
Martin era there was a drought you know
from about 76 to 80
4 or something and
uh a guy I knew in Detroit named Mark
Ridley started a club called The Comedy
Castle
based on The Comedy Store in LA and he
said I'll bring a headliner and hire two
locals and make three make it three and
we were also a lot of us were at the
time on a show called make me laugh
which was on every night at 11 five
nights a week in place of the news
and it was really popular for a while
and everybody was on that Bruce Baum and
Coulier and and uh
Gary shanling and mule deer and and
Tim tomerson and I'm trying to think who
else
I mean so many comics and we would go
out and put so the comedy clip clip uh
Castle started and then I think zany
started right after that and
Atlanta a club there was the Cleveland
Comedy Club there was the Pittsburgh
comedy club and
they would always pay the headliners
pretty well
you know but the local acts would get
paid what local acts in New York and La
got paid yeah and I don't think I listen
I'm not condoning this I think they
should be paying more but that's I think
I've always been the thinking but I do
know
when I talk to my friends that are
headlining these comedy clubs which are
beautiful clubs Now The Improv clubs and
all these clubs all across the country
they're making a hell of a lot more than
I made for headlining
you know and I was one of the top head
paid headliners
and one of the first you said so that's
really cool yeah well I was the first
one of the first I was the first at Mark
Ridley's club which was one of the first
clubs but but like giggles and they were
called they were called Everything
Chuckles and uh Chuckle Hut you know the
comedy crock pot you know what they just
through every name they could at this
club
but they paid us pretty well
and especially for me because I was only
19 20 years old you know yeah
and
but I I know that the middle Act and the
first guy
probably got 25 bucks a night 50 bucks a
night
same now and by the way by the well by
the way if that's bothering you get out
of the business now and go figure out
how to make money on Wall Street
you know because you know
got to pay your dues you know
you got to pay your dues and and and and
it's in the beginning it's not about
money it's about getting up on stage huh
right now I'd almost pay for people to
put me on stage
I called Bert Chrysler today begging for
him to throw me on this [__] belly
room
uh thing he's having the [__] didn't
even call me back
so you know I mean there's probably so
many other people bugging him to put to
be on to the SE things you know there's
just you know right now it's hard to get
stage time so if you're complaining
about only getting 25 or 50 bucks
you're kind of looking at it wrong
and what what would you say is your
worst in your comedy career like the I
always ask comics on here like their
worst bombing like the worst time
they've ever bombed or a show that's
just Unforgettable they'll never forget
I want to audition for The Tonight Show
at a at a on a sound stage in
Burbank
and they had about eight Comics that
they were considering putting on The
Tonight Show
and they had they had Freddie de Cordova
and all the producers there and you know
about 20 other people
and I followed a guy named Bill Bill
uh Bruce martyr Bruce no Bruce Marr
and he
Bruce yeah his name was Bruce Mar
and not Bill Maher Bruce Martin but he
what part of his act was he'd take a raw
chicken out and put his hand up it and
spin it around
and but she's fine that was his choice
you know but and I was I was just a
manologist you know I just stood there
and told jokes and he walked off the
stage and the stage was soaking wet and
I walked on I came up the steps walked
on and slipped and fell on my ass
I just fell so bad that
I couldn't like recover from it
and I bombed and also all the Tonight
Show producers and all these people were
there just staring at me
and I just wanted to go it was the
[__] guy who put his hand up a
chicken's ass blame him don't put him on
the show
but I didn't get the show at that point
but you were still one of the youngest
people to get on The Tonight Show
I was yeah I was
and and I mean I eventually got on the
show but but that first time stuck with
me and then I remember
it's funny because you you remember
bombs and you remember uh bad reviews I
I was playing Pine Knob in Detroit which
is a big outdoor Amphitheater
and I was opening for I believe I was
opening for Andy Williams who was like a
kind of a
you know middle of the road singer but
he was big he was a huge star I mean you
don't know who he is right but he was a
huge star he filled Pine Knob which was
8 000 seats you know
but uh
he had an older audience and he was a
crooner
and I went out and did my Act and the
next day the Detroit Free Press the
cover the front page of the
entertainment section there was this
reviewer wrote Mike binders jokes that
are obnoxious and that and that was that
was the nicest part of the review
and that was like my hometown and I just
I was so bummed oh
oh that stayed with me forever I could
until about a couple years ago I could
read I could recite you the review by
heart
that's why I always ask because we we
never forget those
no that's right
where'd you start Joel
I started here in Atlanta I'm still in
Atlanta so oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so I I
came up in like the the hood rooms of
Atlanta white people didn't mess with me
for a long time so I was doing all the
hood rooms the strip clubs and the
nightclubs and
I've you know I've had the light shut
off on me and all that so it
I'm white boy Joel around these parts
that's great are there good clubs in
Atlanta
good comedy clubs yeah yeah we have four
yeah we have four clubs here
so it's it's a good scene it's I I came
up here I always wanted to just kind of
build it from here instead of like
moving
um so it's smart it's been the longer
road but I feel like it'll take me
farther so um
I'm great I think what you're doing is
great because not only I mean you've
built your own show and your own you've
you know I say to my son my son just
wrote and directed his first movie and
acted in it and and he um
for nothing you know and
but you he and he edited it
and then he edited the Bob Saget tribute
on Netflix and I said you know and he
but that's not what he wants to do he
wants to be an actor I said but look at
all the tools you've picked up
look at you know look at all the tools
you've picked up along the way Joel you
know it's like
if you had just come out and been
another guy waiting in line on audition
nights at these clubs or working at a
camera store out here you wouldn't know
how to create a series and how to you
know you know all the things you know
how to create and and I that's what I
think is so fantastic is
I mean I tell this story a lot but when
I came back to do The Comedy Store
documentary the biggest thing I noticed
was
the the regulars that were working out
when we were when I was there and I'm
talking about the bigger names you know
the guy they'd come in and they'd go to
the front booth and go who's in the
audience
who's here
you know just in case you know they get
some show or movie part or anything
and
it became obvious to me very quickly
that the comics working today never
bother asking because they don't give a
damn
they don't care who's in the audience
they're they run their own Studios they
run their own they create their own
world you know yeah and if someone wants
to see them great but if not [__] them
you know and I and I think it's just so
great
I agree I agree
I mean I have so much respect for the
rogans and the Burrs and and the
Whitney's of the world you know I mean
it's just amazing that and Sebastian and
these people are
they're in charge of their own lives you
know and I don't care how big you were
back then you know you weren't you know
and sometimes like Burl said to me yeah
you know it's uh I'm I'm riding high but
who knows how long it's going to last
and I'm like thinking he doesn't
understand
it used to didn't last long because
they picked somebody else but when
you're the boss
you get to do it as long as you want to
do it and as long as you're doing it
good
that's wild even someone at Bill Burr's
level is like oh but this could end at
any moment like they're not
it's true it's true unless it's fake
humility which I I wouldn't put past
them
we'll have to ask him about that false
humility yeah what's your comedy advice
just fake it just fake it
no no no I would say just the obvious
just be you you know write about your
life
right you know and the other thing I've
learned
that I didn't do great
but I learned it
directing other Comics being gone from
it
and um you gotta have an end
Leno used to always [__]
bug me behind it you don't have an ant
get a [__] ant put an act together
you know and I just was always like uh
what do you guys want to talk about and
or I'd have 15 minutes and then I'd try
other [__] or you know and it was just
it was really
and like you know recently I saw Mark
Norman who I just love this guy I just
love him
but this guy went up at the Irvine
Improv and he did an hour 10 I think you
know and it was boom boom boom boom boom
and he you know he asked a couple
questions from the audience and messed
around a little but he he knew exactly
where he was going and exactly where he
was ending and he understood he's there
to entertain them not to entertain
himself you know
and for me I spent a lot of years just
wanting to entertain myself
you know yeah it was it was like a split
personality between desperately needed
the Audi the audience approval and just
I want to do it my way you know and and
it
Leno used to
harangue me you know just
have an act
have a [__] act
you know you guys would play Risk
together and stuff right you guys went
way back oh yeah we were we were really
close for a long time he was like I was
like his little buddy for years
but but the point is you know
I really see it I mean the reason Bill
Burr is a genius
is because he's got a crazy mind a but B
because he works so hard at it and he he
understands it's such a craft he doesn't
he doesn't see it as a uh
you know celebrities he sees it as he's
a cabinet maker or something you know he
crafts these routines and jokes and and
one thing man like I did paper tiger and
I did Red Rocks okay and both of those
shows two shows each
we ended up picking the second show on
one and the second show or the other but
both of those shows were the exact same
in terms of his material
he had put a a set together
and there was he wasn't taking chances
that he was going to kill he
you know and he really worked it and put
it together and I know this sounds
stupid but I never understood that when
I was doing stand up I never understood
that
huh sting yeah well I was young first of
all you know I started so young
and I never really I never had a problem
because I don't know I just I guess
because I was young and I was crazy and
I was always messed up on drugs I I just
got over you know but if you had to
record it or do it for an important
night
it could go bad
and I've just come to really realize
that
you know you got to have a show you you
gotta you gotta be there for them
yeah
are these two long answers for you Joel
or is that it because
no these are great fun no no no I'm
listening
no I'm listening that's half half of
this show for me is just like listening
I I'm just I just absorb all of these
you know so everything you're saying is
super relevant and helpful because I do
think there are especially younger
Comics who do see someone like a Bill
Burr who's getting away with like maybe
edgy topics and they and younger Comics
may see that and be like oh it's because
he's saying it with attitude but they
don't understand there's Decades of
honing the craft to be able to start
pulling these topics off and young
Comics kind of got to learn the rules
before they break them
and by the way uh bill doesn't think
it's not they're not topics they're
they're things that he's built that he
knows are funny and he's figured out
after night after night after night how
to turn them into a routine he's not
he's not a guy that would go I better do
something on abortion you know he goes I
got something on abortion let me work on
it you know ah okay
that's all and he just writes all on
stage
no no I no I think I think I think from
interviewing them and from talking to
him I think he gets an idea driving
around
and then he jumps up on stage and tries
it out and then goes okay that worked
this way this way and he just he worked
he he's always jumping up somewhere he's
always working it out honing that you
know he ends Red Rock with this amazing
routine that I don't want to talk about
because it's so [__] good I want
people not to be but he worked on that
thing
for a good year and a half and it just
got better and better and better and
then it gets longer and then it gets
shorter and you know he's he's a he's
he's a master for a reason he he
takes he
he the work is very important to him the
product is very important to him I I
don't think he gives two shits about the
prizes
um
good to know all right let me get into
uh some some viewer questions here let's
get into some of these live questions
here thank you all so much for posting
your questions and people are showing a
lot of just love and gratitude for even
being here which is so nice
so uh totally yeah it's nice
uh yeah we're all about being positive
and supportive here we're all about
Comics helping comics
so the first one here I have a site
called standupworld.com yeah people love
that too yeah yeah and you know I'm one
of the things
there's two things one
we're gonna profile and we are profiling
a lot of new Comics new things
and new technology but also a lot of
comics that we've lost that people might
not know about and like we just did this
piece on Flip Wilson which I was really
happy to do wow because a lot because he
was one of my favorites growing up and
now a lot of people don't know Flip
Wilson
so I think it goes two ways one you
gotta bring the new people along
and two you gotta make sure the people
that are gone are forgotten
yeah and I just put a link to that
website in the in the live chat and I'll
definitely put that in the show notes
when I release this as the podcast as
well because yeah that website's amazing
and you're writing a lot of cool
articles but you also have all sections
of like podcasts and different so I feel
like it's really like a place to like
showcase and celebrate comedy
yeah that's right we have everybody's
Instagram and podcasts and tour dates
and books and everything yeah
beautiful all right so I just put that
in the link and and it doesn't make one
God damn penny
but I love it
my world all right we're here
for the game out here
that's right
um so Ryan skrilla asked uh how do you
shift gears from dark humor on projects
like Ray Donovan to silly relatable
rom-com like catch-all that is stand up
to the cat wait really I didn't do it it
would be called ketchup
it's y'all that is oh wait how do you
shift gears from dark humor like Ray
Donovan to silly relatable rom-coms to
stand up that's what he
it's really just like
you know playing another sport or doing
another game you know and I I look I I
like really dark stuff I I like dramatic
stuff I did that movie rain over me with
Adam Sandler and I did
black or white with Kevin Costner and
but at the same token I I like just
going for the laugh too you know that's
fun too I I made a movie that really
kind of started me as in movies called
sex monster which one you know the HBO's
Festival best actor and best movie award
and we made it for nothing you know and
and uh
that was just a balls out sex comedy you
know but uh
but and then I you know and and one of
the probably the best
fun I ever had making a movie in my life
was a huge bomb which has had a great
afterlife was a movie called blank man
with Damon Wayans and David Alan Grier
but but that was just a silly comedy and
it was great I had so much so
you know I've had agents tell me that's
why my career didn't go better as a
Movie Maker because I was all over the
map but I kind of like being all over
the man
nice uh the next one here and we'll just
uh we'll just try to run through these
so this one this is from one of our OG
members uh Bobby Sutton she just had an
epiphany she said she's like I was
supposed to hear this today I've been
putting off projects I want to do for
myself for so long to help people
use my talent for their benefit without
any reward what's the best way to exit a
work situation that no one
has been in for a long time while
keeping them as friends
the back door late at night when no one
knows you left
you just quietly leave
she's not part of this anymore yeah just
leave yeah I just yeah just leave just
but also
or just be honest just say hey you know
it's time to go it's time to go I'm not
getting any juice out of this anymore I
love you but I gotta go
all right yeah just being transparent
you know what I'm gonna you know what
I'm gonna do a real quick I think I have
to um
I have to change this yeah yeah go for
it
I think I think this thing the the
um the batteries that running out on
this thing yeah or it looks it looks
like it's a thermometer or something huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah either that or I've
got the mumps or something but someone
wants to give me a check your camera has
code yeah
I don't know if if it shuts down I'll
just shut to my camera's webcam okay
cool my computer
but I appreciate you setting that up
though that it definitely makes a big
difference so um
uh the next one here from Alan Michael
Harbor
um
what was it like working with Tom Cruise
uh it was fantastic he was a great guy
and he had an amazing sense of humor
and he just was funny as hell and he
loved to laugh
so it was really it was great he pulled
some serious gags on me and
Andy um
he just was fun he likes his job he
works hard it was a good that was a
great time Steven Spielberg and
Tom Cruise that was a great time
what was the gag
I came back from lunch one day you know
there was a scene where they my
character gets thrown out a window like
18 stories high shot out a window and
there's a guy dressed like me in the
same clothes with a wig that looks like
my hair and Spielberg and him and
Giannis Kaminsky are arguing no no no no
limit and time was going just let me ask
Mike if he'll do the stunt I do my
stunts let me ask Mike and they say Mike
we got a photo double but it's not gonna
look good can just look and look out
about three stories down they built this
whole ramp and there was a giant air
mattress huge he goes just can I just
shoot you out the window
and you land backwards it'll be easy
I've done it a million times and like
I'm like this kid in high school with
the cool kids
pissing my pants
and I go I guess I could try and time
goes yeah okay so just and those guys go
oh far out Mike thank you so much we
didn't want to use a stunt McDouble on
this stunt
and time goes just fall backwards and
don't make sure it's you're flat because
if not you're gonna snap your neck and
it just starts laughing his ass off and
these guys in the whole crew just goes
down they set me up at lunch like let's
see if we can get him to [__] say
yeah I'll do this stunts
and
it was hysterical and and uh he did he
kept doing things like that you know it
was just he just has fun
he messing with people on the set and
just but it's always with love I gotta
tell you it's not as I'm telling you
maybe
it comes off like a mean thing he did
but it wasn't it was it was pure
to have fun
he's an amazing guy
it's awesome uh Alexander K when you
come across a new comic what about their
jokes or them as a performer uh like
Sparks your attention
I don't know you know I mean I I don't
know I always watch so many new
comedians at the comic store then I saw
this woman Annie Letterman and she just
her she her jokes were so different and
unique and I guess you can still hear me
right yeah I can hear you yeah all right
let me just switch the camera if you
don't mind yeah yeah
I guess I gotta go to your uh
because yeah we're all we can still hear
you and such
yeah let me uh so I guess I gotta go to
your uh preference or something or does
anyone know how to do this yeah
we have Mike binder using technology
right now this is this is a hot breath
exclusive
yeah it's like it's like Grandpa
checking email it's like is this you
can't get off my Instagram
my email's at Hotmail
what what what's the name of this site
you're using here okay I got it all
right and preferences
stay with you can you can ask me
anything you want and I'll just cool
yeah yeah yeah we'll get to um thanks
everyone for posting your questions we
have about 10 more minutes so we'll uh
we'll get to as many as we can here
um
the next one this is from Johannes it
said which methods do you use to write
jokes
I just get ideas and I and I am
I I just get ideas and I honestly I just
go for them you know I I I'll try them
out on stage and then same thing you
know try to make them a little bit
better every time
just on stage
yeah but I I know I said I actually sit
down and write them out and work them
out and try to make them good you know
but by the same token
I am
you know I I I I I do off stage
like if I've I've got an idea about you
know my wife and I traveling I'll I'll
just write it out and play with it and
really try to get it as far down the
road as I can without taking it to the
stage
yeah because in researching you I heard
you say you'll write for like three or
four hours a day
well but I also you got to remember the
other side of it is is
that I
you know the I've really developed a
strong discipline for um screenplay
writing because so a lot of that when I
was talking about when I was talking
about my movies you know
how were you able to develop that
discipline because that consistency in
writing is just it's like doing dead
lifts man
well that's what it is you know you have
to you gotta really
get that consistency you know you really
have to um
I write every day I write every day now
I'm writing some stand up but I write
every single day
all right next question here from Drew
beekler from a direction point of view
what things do you see in specials that
people are doing right and doing wrong
oh I I don't know it's a good question
but I mean there's some great specials I
mean that rothaniel was such a piece of
art and yeah you know
you know and
I don't know you know Paul versus new
special I just loved you know mm-hmm so
I I don't really I think it's there's a
lot of things to do right and there's a
lot of things to do wrong you know and
and I I think
it's it's like a piece of heart you
can't say well that's wrong you know
it's it's what people want to do you
know uh
I wanted to do a little
beginning thing at paper tiger
with these photographs that we had done
of Bill walking around London and at the
end of the day Netflix said just get the
thing going and Bill agreed with it you
know
and so I I do kind of think that's one
thing sometimes it's just better to get
to get the damn thing going you know
start start this if and you know Bill
and I just produced a special for a a
comedian and now they're talking about
he wants to do a little bit of a or the
uh the other producer wants to put a
little documentary footage with it and
I'm thinking
I don't know I don't know if that works
I don't know if that's gonna work you
know
I think sometimes it's better to just uh
either you're doing a like I'll give you
another really good example we just did
that Bob Saget thing yeah on Netflix
yeah yeah and
you know there was talk about showing
going out of this Comedy Store more and
showing early footage of his and some
home video that he had and and I was
like we gotta stay with the girl we
brought to the dance you know we got to
keep it this real kind of Live Comedy
Store show Memorial if if you want to
turn if it's in a documentary it'll be
like nine other things
all right and uh I I can get I can get
Ricky who works with me to come fix this
but he's in another room and I don't
want to just give you dead air so I'm
trying
oh okay you can go yell at him if you
want
okay hold on one second
yeah
hey Mickey
Ricky
thank you all so much for hanging out
isn't this cool
back to the the the thing and I don't
know how to do it
and I got them thinking that I really
know technology and [__] hey so yeah I
think I might have it I fixed it you
guys
again yeah and then go to settings okay
and then go to the where we were
previously where it was
um price and security
then go to camera yeah and then go to
okay I knew that yeah I knew that yeah
so what do I do now
I knew that wait what do I do now
[Laughter]
and then go back into the go back into
the the program we're using right now
which is this
and then go to
um settings there
oh that's it I probably should have done
that right away okay thank you buddy of
course appreciate it at least you know
the camera yeah yeah no you know what
Joel sorry about that we we knew we knew
this was I thought the battery would
last longer I ordered one of those
I it looked like it overheated it looked
like it was like an overheat thing
no it wasn't an overheated I think the
battery just died okay
so um let's squeeze let's squeeze in two
more here
um
sorry about that anybody that cared oh
we all care you're Mike binder
this is important we're making comedy
history right now Mike yes we are yes we
are this is the Valley Forge of Comedy
this is a big deal right here
This Is Our Big Break we've had over 400
comics on here but this is the one we
had some great comics
they really haven't built on
if if you say so
no I have no believe me I have it yeah I
haven't I haven't reached out
you should
like to his like agent
yeah his manager Dave Becky
oh
okay just reach out I I don't I honestly
I believe me that's the last thing I
would do is try to start booking him
yeah I mean most most of uh the most
like the big names I've gotten have been
from like referral like it's been either
way by the way Paul verzi knows would
could it could help with that that's he
loves Paul
yeah Paul thought he'd already been on
the show because he's like is this the
one where Burr like roasted you and I
was like well not yet but if he if he
says so then let's do it you know
yeah versus great though super nice guy
I love meeting people at his level that
they're like just nice and they care
about helping Comics you know I just
have you had Joe parnick on I have not
no we've got to get Joe bartonik on okay
he is a
funny funny
[__] guy and he tells great stories
and he's got a new special coming out
that they just filmed oh perfect yeah it
was like the time it when people are
like releasing specials or something as
well so
yeah we'll definitely have Joe on too
nice and we'll work on Bill that's right
everyone you heard it here first that's
right he should come on
[__] slacker yeah you see that bill
Mike just said you should come on the
show none of your Hollywood Mansion
getting the Ferrari tell Stallone you'll
call him another day come down the hill
and be on Joe byers' show you bald [__]
yeah
an Applause
two Applause we'll see you soon bill
so maybe
um the last thing we can end with here
maybe it's like
your your favorite
um advice that you've gotten throughout
your career like is something that stuck
out that you just carried with you that
maybe this next generation of comics can
learn and build from
uh you know I'm I'm learning myself you
know that you're always learning and to
me I'm following the guys that are
present day that's you know Bill said
something to me one time that really
struck with me and you know he when I
was doing after right after the
documentary he said the documentary was
great for you because
you're you know comedians from your
generation and now a a newer generation
and you're current and I think you the
current comedians
and the newer ones just starting and
people like you that are coming up right
now have more to offer than
you know some guy that just wants to
tell stories about it and then we went
to Chicago
and we killed you know I think what's
going on now you have to be very very
current in this business and by the way
you need to know how to put your camera
back on when another one fails
how can Comics set themselves apart like
with so many Comics out there
all right you just have to be really
funny and you have to love what you're
doing the audience smells it the
audience smells that
Mark Norman loves comedy mm-hmm and then
he tells him comedy
like he loves it he loves comedy you
know
Shane Gillis loves comedy he loves being
funny mm-hmm
be funny I love it well Mike binder
thank you so much I mean the the last
thing we do here do you mind just
looking at the camera saying your name
and why people should listen to hot
breath
hey I'm Mike binder and you should
listen to hot breath because you're
going to learn a lot about comedy and
while you're on the show they have
people that rifle through your apartment
so very important
that you come on you listen and you pay
close attention and you ignore the
noises in the other rooms perfect Mike
binder thank you so much for being on
hot breath standupworld.com is there
anything else you want to promote here
uh Red Rocks live at Red Rocks next
Friday Bill Burr his best special ever
and
I love it so
thank you so much everyone for hanging
out thanks for having me on I really
appreciate it I'm sorry about the
technical problems but no worries at all
my friend have a good day okay okay cool
bye